you should know mr. president that the
United States military is all in on this
national emergency and the great sailors
and medical professionals of this
tremendous hospital ship are eager to
get underway and start their very
important mission as the nation
aggressively response to the corona
virus pandemic the Department of Defense
is focused on three priorities first
protecting our servicemembers civilians
and their families we are committed to
taking all necessary measures to
safeguard the well-being of our most
important resource our people second
remaining prepared to carry out our core
national security missions and to defend
the United States against any threat and
third continuing to support president
Trump's whole-of-government whole of
nation response to the corona virus for
several weeks the Department of Defense
has been surging personnel capabilities
and equipment to help slow the spread of
the virus
thousands of National Guard troops are
mobilized across the country conducting
a variety of essential tasks ranging
from planning to logistics to medical
support active duty units are moving
critical supplies and equipment and
medical personnel to some of the
nation's most heavily impacted areas the
department's world-class doctors and
scientists are at the forefront of
infectious disease research working
alongside our government and private
sector efforts to accelerate a vaccine
and therapeutics for this virus and now
in this great time of need the president
has directed the deployment of our
nation's most powerful symbols of
medical care and compassion
the Navy's to hospital ships the mercy
and the comfort both ships have a
tremendous history of humanitarian
assistance and have provided care for
people throughout the world
this exceptional legacy continues as
they now take care of their fellow
Americans
the skilled medical professionals who
will set sail on the comfort will play a
critical role in freeing up capacity in
hospital beds in the New York area I'd
like to thank them for their sacrifices
and further commitment to the well-being
of the American people
finally I'd like to thank President
Trump for his bold leadership and
support to the men and women of the
United States Armed Forces
this is an unprecedent time for our
nation and your leadership mr. president
is uniting the American people to defeat
this virus I am confident we will get
through this together we will prevail
thank you and it's my great honor to now
welcome the President of the United
States and our commander-in-chief
President Donald Trump thank you very
much mark and you're doing a fantastic
job and our country appreciates it very
much and thank you everybody for being
here today I'm deeply honored to be at
Naval Station Norfolk the largest naval
base anywhere in the world and the home
to the most powerful fleet that has ever
sailed the seas I just passed some of
the most beautiful and frankly the most
highly lethal ships that I have ever
seen in my life and there are a lot of
them and they're in better shape now
than they have been for many many
decades with what we're doing we're
grateful to be joined by commander of
the u.s. fleet forces Admiral
Christopher Grady and commander of the
u.s. 2nd fleet Vice Admiral woody Lewis
thank you both for being here we
appreciate it very much
as we gather today our country is at war
with an invisible enemy
we are marshalling the full power of the
American nation economic scientific
medical and military to vanquish the
virus and we will do that today I'm here
to express my profound gratitude to the
educated servicemembers who will soon be
on the frontlines of this fight in a few
moments the crew of the navy hospital
ship USNS comfort which is really
something will embark for New York City
where they will join the ranks of tens
of thousands of amazing doctors nurses
and medical professionals who are
battling to save American lives this
great ship behind me is a 70,000 ton
message of hope and solidarity to the
incredible people of New York a place I
know very well a place I love we're here
for you we fighting for you and we are
with you all the way and we always will
be
you have the unwavering support of the
entire nation the entire government and
the entire American people after being
rushed out of maintenance with historic
speed it was supposed to be here for
four weeks and they did it in four days
the comfort will arrive at Pier 90 in
Manhattan on Monday three weeks ahead of
schedule its crew will begin treating
patients on Tuesday it will be met in
New York Harbor by Governor Cuomo I just
spoke with he's very excited and they
need the help to skilled sailors and
civilian Mariners aboard this ship will
provide a critical search capacity for
the New York metropolitan area their
mission will be to care for New Yorkers
who do not have the virus but who
require urgent care in other words
they'll be using this people will be
coming out of hospitals who don't have
the virus and they'll be on the ship
where they have great operating rooms
and great facilities and the places
inbound on land will be where people
that have the virus will be
so the people with the virus will not be
on ship the ship will be used for people
having operations and other things other
than that by serving these emergency
patients away from the hospitals
beds will be opened up all over the city
for those who are infected this ship can
handle a lot of people so it will open
capacity all over the city and it will
be ready to address any life-threatening
medical emergency it is stocked it
stocked to the brim with equipment and
medicines and everything you can think
of importantly by treating non infected
patients remotely on the ship it will
help to halt very strongly the
transmission of the virus the comfort
sistership on the west coast the USNS
mercy arrived ahead of schedule
substantially in Port yesterday Governor
Gavin Newsom was very thankful for it
they're working very hard in California
it's performing a similar mission for
the people of Los Angeles and the people
of California as the USNS comfort gets
underway it is fully loaded with 12
operating rooms and they are fully
equipped 1,000 hospital beds a medical
laboratory a pharmacy in optometry lab
digital radiology a cat-scan to oxygen
producing plants and a helicopter deck
which will be used very actively it also
bears our military's greatest weapon of
all a crew of nearly 1,200 outstanding
members of the United States Navy and I
thank them very much among the sailors
departing today are some of the finest
doctors nurses technicians orderlies and
medical staff anywhere in the world
these are true professionals and no one
performs better under pressure when
lives are on the line these are
incredible people
we will stop at nothing to protect the
health of New Yorkers and the health of
the people of our country in their hour
of need I also want to remind everyone
about the CDC's latest guidance if you
are from the New York metropolitan area
and you travel elsewhere we need you to
self quarantine for 14 days to help us
contain the spread of the virus and I am
now considering will make a decision
very quickly very shortly a quarantine
because it's such a hot area of New York
New Jersey and Connecticut we'll be
announcing that one way or the other
fairly soon this does not apply to
people such as truckers from outside the
New York area who are making deliveries
or simply transiting through it won't
affect trade in any way the Army Corps
of Engineers and FEMA are racing to
build temporary hospitals which are now
completed by the way in record time for
hospitals for medical centers and in
speaking with the governor this morning
we're giving them an additional four
large tents which they need very badly
and the emergency medical stations in
New York are top of the line you have
them in not only New York but in
California and Illinois we'll be adding
some to other states also I've empowered
our nation's governors with the
resources to call up the National Guard
and authorize the activation of ready
reserves two big words ready
reserves FEMA has shipped or delivered
11.6 million n95 respirators 26 million
surgical masks 5.2 million face shields
and a lot are being made of all of the
things I just named right now we have
millions in
millions of new medical items being made
as we speak and purchased four point
three million surgical gowns 22 million
gloves and 8100 ventilators we have
moved rapidly to mobilize every
instrument of American power this week I
invoke the defense production act to
compel General Motors to carry out
federal contracts for ventilators and I
think they're going to do a great job I
have to say that we're also working with
the major ventilator companies in the
United States all big-name companies all
companies that do ventilators so they
won't need extra time and they're
gearing up and they'll be working 24
hours around the clock and they have
been they've been doing a fantastic job
to accomplish a historic ramp up and a
ramp up in the kind of numbers that were
talking about and we make too many
that's going to be okay because I spoke
with the prime minister of the UK
yesterday Boris Johnson he tested as you
know positive and before I even was able
to get a word out of him he said I said
how you doing he said we need
ventilators the UK needs ventilators a
lot of countries need ventilators badly
it's a tough thing to make it's a very
complicated and expensive piece of
equipment I would say more so than a car
you're talking about expensive
complicated equipment so I hope we soon
will have enough that we can help other
countries with ventilators a lot of
countries need them in the next 100 days
America will make or require three times
more ventilators than we do in an entire
year we are so geared up at Boeing Ford
Honeywell 3m Haynes and other great
American companies factory floors and
manufacturing lines are being converted
to produce the respirators protective
masks face shields and other vital
equipment and those companies have been
amazing and Boeing is giving us their
cargo moving
the biggest cargo movers anywhere in the
world and we're going to be using them
to ship certain types of equipment to
various states hundreds of millions of
Americans are also making tremendous
sacrifices of the homefront in a
historic drive to support our great
workers and businesses I signed into law
the single largest economic relief
package in American history you saw that
yesterday the 2.2 trillion and think of
that 2.2 trillion but it goes to six
point two trillion depending on what we
decide this legislation delivers job
retention loans for small businesses to
help them keep workers on payroll
expanded unemployment benefits and
direct cash payments to American
citizens and these are very substantial
payments a family of four will be
getting approximately $3,400 this
legislation also provides massive
increases in funding for hospitals who
need it for disaster relief fund and
critical life-saving medical supplies
we're spending a tremendous amount of
money on medical supplies we're trying
to get it to the point needed directly
as opposed to our supply lines so it can
go directly to where they need it
without having to go through a long
process I don't want to say bureaucratic
but we have not this group of people has
worked so incredibly hard and the energy
and the speed with which they're
delivering everything has been really
admired by everybody everybody's talking
about it the job they're doing my
administration has also taken action to
to spend and suspend federal student
loan payments so we're suspending and
that means suspending in every sense of
the word student loan payments so that
the students that are not able to take
advantage of what's going on obviously
for obvious reasons they will be the
payments suspended we've temporarily
stopped federal evictions and
foreclosures we postpone tax day until
July which is a big thing first time
that's happened and waived regulations
to speed new treatments to the market
and we have new treatments coming on
rapidly we're doing very well we think
with vaccines and we're doing very very
well with hopefully or potentially cures
we're looking at a lot of different
alternatives a lot of different
medicines that would be game-changer the
battle in which we're now engaged has
inflicted many hardships on our nation
and our families tremendous hardship on
some families and much death much death
but through it all the world has
witnessed the unyielding resolve of our
incredible American people we are not
only a country of vast resources we're a
nation of colossal strength towering
spirits soaring patriotism and
exceptional character and you're showing
it to the entire world at this moment
there are 151 countries throughout the
world that are under attack by this
horrible invisible enemy 151 conscious
and we're in touch with a lot of them
our professionals are the best in the
world but who would ever think 151
countries are under attack we are one
family bound together by love and
loyalty the eternal traits so perfectly
embodied by the extraordinary men and
women aboard the ship and the men and
women at this beautiful scenic but
really tough base this base is something
thank you very much its base is
something very very special with the
courage of our doctors and nurses with
the skill of our scientists and
innovators with the determination of the
American people and with the grace of
God we will win this war and we will win
this war quickly with as little death as
possible
and when we achieve our victory this
victory your victory we will emerge
stronger and more United than ever
before
we are going to be at a level of
preparedness and case something like
this should ever happen again and God
willing it won't but we are prepared
what we've done in building systems
we're now the number one tester anywhere
in the world by far we're testing more
in one day than other countries are
testing in weeks and months we've
learned a lot and I cannot be more
thankful to the American people and I
can say this and I can say this from the
bottom of my heart I am very proud to be
your president thank you very much and
God bless you all thank you thank you
very much
[Music]